el 11 de marzo de 2011 un terremoto
sacudió de forma violenta la costa
pacífica de japón su potencia que llegó
a los 9,1 grados en la escala de richter
provocó un gran tsunami que arrasó con
prácticamente todo el litoral y mató a
más de 19 mil personas miles de
ciudadanos perdieron todo y se vieron
obligados a desplazarse aunque ya no
haya terremotos todavía sigo sintiendo
que la tierra tiembla es aterrador
pero lo más grave sucedió en la central
nuclear de fukushima daichi cuyas
instalaciones estaban al borde del mar y
fueron afectadas por el oleaje la falta
de un muro de contención hizo que el
agua inundara una gran parte y que el
sistema de seguridad fallara esto generó
una fusión nuclear parcial en tres
reactores explosiones de hidrógeno y
fugas radioactivas muy elevadas se
estima que unas 160 mil personas
tuvieron que huir de sus poblaciones
debido a la radiación un desastre del
que se acusó a la empresa tepco
nos gustaría disculparnos desde el fondo
de mi corazón por haber causado tantos
problemas y dolor a tanta gente y a la
sociedad en general como local
oa dimensiones a pesar de los graves
cargos de negligencia que se imputaron a
sus tres ex directivos todos salieron
absueltos en 2019 diez años después
siguen las tareas de reconstrucción de
la zona que se prolongarán hasta 2031
aunque el gobierno ha permitido regresar
a muchas zonas más de 36.000 personas
siguen fuera de sus hogares y existe un
gran miedo a volver y sufrir daños por
la radiación todavía presente en algunos
lugares